[Music]
a quarter century ago one of music's
most influential and brightest stars was
gunned down right here in las vegas on
september 7 1996 hip-hop superstar tupac
shakur was shot four times while sitting
in a car at a stoplight he died six days
later at a local hospital
it's hard to believe you know that it's
been that long but
this shooting that happened just off the
las vegas strip was one of the biggest
crimes that happened in las vegas
history
and his death was just devastating and
millions of fans rocked the music world
the mob museum will mark the 25th
anniversary of this tragic event with
hip-hop legend chuck d and others
delving into the events that led to
tupac's death controversies that
followed and shakur's cultural legacy
we are bringing together a great group
of panelists this wednesday edi i mean
he was an original member of the outlaws
tupac shakur's friend he was traveling
behind
mr shakur during the night of the
shooting this program will take place in
the museum's historic courtroom and
guests can attend a meet and greet with
the panelists tickets for one night in
las vegas the 25th anniversary of tupac
shakur murder are now sold out
hard to believe it's been 25 years brian
so many people still talking about this
because it's one of these unsolved
mysteries a lot of fingers pointed at
different players in all this but still
no one ever has been charged yeah we all
remember it so well and he is one of
those artists that the music really does
live on now a quarter century later such
a powerful musical artist and his music
still has an impact